[Music]
capsum slamming in Kenya is a profitable
Venture but many farmers struggle
especially during the germination stage
with the right guidance however you can
grow cups scums from seed to harvest and
make the most of these high demand
vegetable in this tutorial we will walk
you through every step from selecting
the best cap scum seeds to planting from
test control to harves in now we shall
cover the following topics the caps in
Kenya the best time to plant cap scums
in Kenya the best soil for caps scums
farming the best cap scum variety to
grow in Kenya how to raise cap scum seed
drinks caps scum's planting and spacing
cap scam fertilizer application schedule
caps scum's past and control methods and
finary CS scams diseases and how to
control
them the ccam market in Kenya ccams
enjoy a stud demand in Kenya
particularly in the Mass market and
grocery stores Brokers absorb around 70%
of the total production making it easier
for Farmers to sell in bulk and secure
fast
revenues C scums prices typically range
from 30 shillings to 80 Shillings per
kilo fluctuating based on supply and
demand prices are highest during the
times of extreme
shortage the best time to plant cups
scams in Kenya for the highest profits
ideal time to plant CS scamps in Kenya
is February and September this allows
you to harvest during Easter and
Christmas festive season when the demand
is highest planting this month ensures
your crop are ready for Harvest when the
prices are pick to maintain a steady
income ensure a continuous Supply by
stuggling your planting and harvesting
times buyers prefers farmers who can
provide consistent deliveries regardless
of the
season the best soil for cups comes
farming before investing in caps scum
farming ensure your soil is suitable
caps scums thrive in deep fertile well
drained room soils avoid planting in
Fertile in fields previously used for
potato or tomato farming as these crops
share paste and diseases that could
damage your caps scum
crop the best cap scum variety is to
grow in Kenya for better yields choose
high yield hybrid caps scum varieties
these are more resistant to diseases and
paste here are two of the best varieties
for Kenyan Farmers number one Maxell
Maxell is a popular open pollinated
sweet paper variety known for its heavy
fruiting the fruits weigh around 200 g
and each plant can yield 4 to 5 kg
Maxell matures in about 90 days and has
a high tolerance to Tomato mosaic
virus Maxell variety planting density or
the planting population is around 900
plants per 200 200 140 square m or
20,000 lb per
acre the second good variety for for
Farmers is super Bell F1 super Bell is a
hybrid variety with broky ropes and V
fleshy fruits it has a mild flavor and
high resistance to Tomato mic virus and
potato virus harvesting starts 65 to 75
days after transplanting it can yield up
to 25 tons per acre
how trat C scum seedings seedings
establishment is where most Farmers fail
C scums seeds take four to 5 weeks to
establish however this can be
accelerated by soaking seats in an
Optimizer or city shooter solution
before planting SE seeds shallowly and
cover them with black paper to shorten
the germination period by up to 2
weeks how to plant capsicum and the
spacing for best result space capsicum
plant 45 cm by 45 cm this allows for
20,000 plants per acre use well
decomposed fard manure andate a valer
before transplanting after transplanting
drench the plants with insect sides like
thunder and a f feed like City shooter
to protect against catoms and other
paste capsicums are fertilizer
application schedule this is how you
should now apply fertilizers from
planting to harvesting on 14 days after
transplanting apply dap to promote Loot
and fer growth 40 days after
transplanting apply NPK 17 to stimulate
flowering 60 days after transplanting
apply C fertilizer to enhance fruit
enlargement additionally use nitrogen
potassium and calcium FIA fertilizers
like easy grow vegetative Advanced K and
Cal marks to boost plant health and
fruit produ prodution
further caps scum paste and how to
control
them these are the most destructive
paste in capam familyi number one lead
spidermites these are tiny paste that
feed on the underside of the Rees
causing yellowing and upward cing to
control them apply profile at the rate
of 10 ml per 20 L of water or escort at
the rate of 8 ml per 20 L of water
the second past is white fries white
fries stack nutrients from the Caps
plant Heering photosynthesis infested
leaves show white waxy material and to
control apply thander all profine seites
at the late of 10 ml per 20 L of
water and the third one is catws these
are these are P that cut seedings near
the soil level drench the soil with
profile at the rate of 3 ml per lit or
Pentagon at the rate of 1 ml per liter
to control them the other one is loot
not nematodes neat called cause loot
soiling leading to reduced Vigor and
plant depth drench the soil with Alon at
the late of 0.5 m per lit or Mas at the
late of 10 m per 20
l cap scum diseases and how to control
them the most destructive disease is
bright it is caused by Fungus phool
capsa that leads to Rapid Folia flute
and lutro to control apply R gold at the
rate of 50 g per 20 l or mistress at the
rate of 30 G per 20 lit the best way
here is to prevent the
infection the next disease is dowy M
this disease causes yellow spot on the
Leaf surfaces and Browning leading to
Leaf Drop and sunb to prevent down M
apply at least little gold at the rate
of 50 g per 20 L of water the other
disease is fium whe fium whe is caused
by fium oxum this soil bone fungus leads
to vein clearing yellowing and wieling
to control fium whe drain the soil with
absolute aate of 10 m per 20 L of water
absolute is fungicide the other disease
which is very very critical is bacteria
weight this bacterial disease causes
wieling of young leaves and
discoloration of vascular tissues contr
it apply green cup at the rate of 2.5 g
per liter which is a copper based
product this will tend to suppress the
spread of the
fungus capsum farming in Kenya can be
highly profitable if you allow the light
if you follow the light steps from seed
selection P control and harvesting with
proper so preparation disease management
and continuous harvesting you can
maximize your yeld and profit throughout
the year we really really hope that you
learned something from this tutorial and
we hope to see you on the next one in
case of any question complaint let us
know